wow it's so clean
more than just lightsaber wipes you got
a cleaning lady
bi-weekly charlotte well well well
okay madman with it you got the fresh
walls
steam curtains glade plugins
acting like i can tell you when i told
you okay i stand corrected
you found a good spot for it
thanks
can i use your bathroom before i go yeah
uh it's just down the hall on your right
hey look sorry i didn't uh
get back to you i'm just wrapping up
yeah sure
i can still try to make it tonight i'll
uh
i'll keep you posted cool
hey that was candela
yeah y'all are
mean up and she wants to talk
i'm sorry i didn't mean to no
the the lift is probably pissed stuff
yeah okay
it was it was really good seeing you
what if i wanted to stay
i don't know make sure we even
i'm not ready for the night to end yet
tonight made me happy
you make me happy
yeah me too
so so
stay
tell me baby
[Music]
there's no easy way out
you